I've got a new favorite constant to tell you about comes constant.
You live a number. So, um, let me write it out.
Here is my new favorite constant 2.92
(005)
097-7316, going on forever.
That's my new favorite constant because kind of magically,
this is going to create prime numbers for us.
We're gonna use this constant and this formula going to create a sequence
of numbers.
And the next number in your sequence will be taking the
previous number in your sequence. We're gonna round it down.
And that's what that symbol means. It's called the floor function.
You round it down to the nearest integer,
and then we'll multiply that by taking the previous number in the
sequence, subtracting the internship part.
So I guess it's the decimal part. What ad wanted that?
And this is going to give us a sequence of prime numbers,
especially when we are going to round them down as well.
We're going to use that floor function. I'm going to prove it.
We'll start with the constant.
So that's gonna be the first number in our sequence.
Let's start with one first number. My sequence is this thing,
2.9200 and the rest. Um, and by the way,
I will point out that if I round this down,
it's the first prime it's two. Great.
Let's try the next number in my sequence. I've got my formula here. Just saying,
take the previous number,
round it down to it means to take the decimal part and add one.
So it can be multiplying by this
1.9200 and the rest that is going to give me the next number. It's
3.8401. I well, nine and stuff, but out.
So then next prime number we were after it's three. Okay.
So we're hoping this is going to work as well, three and then yeah,
one plus the decimal part 1.8, four zero on stuff.
What's it going?
B is going to be five that's good news and some junk at the end of
it. Pretty important. Junk is going to be important junk.
That's why I'm writing it out. We need this junk and so well,
let's see if it keeps going.
We're hoping for a seven so we can take the internship part, which was five.
We take the decimal part with a one point and then the rest five,
two zero three zero five, eight,
six is equal to what's it going to be
7.601 by two nine and a small junk. One more. Are you,
how are you satisfied? Do you believe me? Oh, let's do it. Okay.
So what do we want the next one to be? So we've got three, five, seven,
11. It should be 11. Okay. So we take our previous one,
which is a seven one plus junk. And if you do your calculation,
yes,
11.210705 and
stuff, and this constant never fails, and this has never fading.
So there is this constant somewhere out there in the world of
numbers with this formula,
which will give you every prime number in order as well, not missing one,
every prime number two, three, five, seven, 11, 13, and forever.
And this constant great was found by
a viewer number five viewer, uh,
who was inspired by one of my previous number five videos.
I have talked about constants that generate prime numbers before.
And I did a video about something called mills constant. So mills constant,
uh, was a constant and a formula in the same kind of way,
which was this I'm going to call it a,
and it was 1.3
(637)
788-3863 and stuff. So this was males constant. And the,
and the formula was kind of like, this is rounding down.
It was males constant to the power,
three to power N and then you would run that down.
It gave you a sequences of primes. Uh, I'll show you what they are.
So the first prime you got for doing this was a tooth.
Then the next one was 11.
Then the next one was 1,361.
And the next one was, Oh, it was a big number.
It was 2 billion, 521 million,
8,887.
And then the little was huge, really, really big. And,
and so it's generating a sequence of primes. Although there are gaps,
there are gaps in this sequence and they get really big as well. So, um,
one of our viewers saw that video. Uh, so that's, uh,
Judy Grabowski and he was at high school at the time.
And he wasn't impressed because, Oh yeah, well it generates primes,
but big gaps, huge primes. He wondered,
could he make a constant? So you could get all the primes,
Bomba bunk in order as well.
So he came up with this idea and he started calculating this
constant with, uh, some of his friends. Uh, so it's Bruno,
uh, Dylan Massey and they created this.
I've never seen this before. I love it. However,
I can tell you now it's not predictive.
This is not going to be able to tell me primes. I don't already know.
I'm afraid. Mill's constant is the same.
We actually using the primes to create this constantly exists
somewhere out there. I'm afraid. I just don't know what it is. Uh,
and I'm sure, um, creating prime Constance doesn't have to be that hard.
You can just have
0.23571113.
That's a prime generating. Constant. Not very interesting. One. Those,
it's not very fun. It's not very surprising.
I think this is kind of fun and surprising,
and it does use properties of primes. They thing,
the primes here using particular properties or primes.
I want to show you what the.
So it's more a case that the primes are generating the constant rather than the
constant generating the prime. Right?
You've caught me out. Yes. It's the primes generating the constant. I mean,
it exists somewhere out there. It'd be lovely.
We could calculate it and then we could use it to predict primes.
I'm afraid. That's not the way it works.
So the number of decimal places, we know this constant too.
Depends on the number of primes we know.
Exactly. Yeah. I'm afraid we are limited by how many primes we know. Uh, but I,
I do like it. I do think it's kind of fun and surprising.
Cause there's a cute little.
Constant. Have I given it a name?
I don't think they've given it a name. I think I know,
I knew you were going to give it a name. Upgrading loves giving thing. Yeah.
I'd say a day, but I did. They have the right to name it. They do. Yeah.
But you know, if they don't hurry up,
I might jump on the bandwagon and he's going to do it fast.
So we'll see the time.
Until of this video. What is the, what is Brady decided? Uh,
so let's see how they made it. So when I saw this,
I actually really enjoyed reverse engineering, how they did it, but, uh,
and you might try that yourself,
but I might give you the ingredients that you need.
And then you can see perhaps for yourself how they did it. First of all,
I'm going to tell you what a general term in the sequence looks like. Uh,
we were calling those F N I'm going to show you how to write FN in terms of
prying numbers. It actually looks like this. It's the nth prime,
and then we're going to subtract one.
And then the next term we're going to add on is the
next prime number.
So it's the end plus one prime subtract one
and divide that by the nth prime.
And then for the next term, you take the next prime number,
which is prime number with the N plus two subscript there
we're subtract one again.
And we're going to divide by the previous primes P and plus
one P N multiply. Yeah.
So we're divided by this, multiply by that. Yes, exactly.
And so you can see what the next term might be.
So the next one is going to be the next prime number still with subtract one
and then dividing by the previous primes we've got, so these prime numbers,
and that's the pattern that goes on forever.
So if you want to work out the first one,
which is our special constant F1, uh,
we'll start with the first prime.
So that would be a two minus one plus,
and then you take the next prime three minus one now divided by two,
and then it's going to be the next prime up five minus one divided by
our previous primes.
And then next prime up
divided by our previous primes.
And that's going to be our constant that I told you at the beginning 2.9,
whatever. So those are starting ingredients.
And then this really important observation,
we're going to use a property of primes called Bertrand's postulate is a big
thing. Actually, when you're studying primes, if you've got the nth prime,
the next prime is obviously bigger,
but it is smaller than twice the nth
prime. I'm not going to do the proof for you.
It's totally possible to do for yourself. When I heard about this constant,
I thought it was great. I loved it. I thought it was good, fun.
I went looking to see if anyone had done it before,
and I've not seen anyone do it before,
but I did find it in one place in a kind of completely
different context. I found it somewhere, which is with this sequence,
something slightly different.
We're going to look for the smallest prime that doesn't
divide N that doesn't divide any sort of factor of N so it's
not a factor of N so for one, the smallest prime, it doesn't divide.
One is two smallest point that doesn't divide. Two is three.
The smallest prime that doesn't divide three is two smallest prime doesn't
divide. Four is three smallest prime.
It doesn't divide five to smallest pine that doesn't divide six. Can't be two,
can't be three. That one's a five.
And then it's a two here and three here and so on. So that's a sequence,
smallest primes that don't divide N and if you look at the average of this
sequence, and this is going on forever,
but if you took the average of this sequence,
it is my new favorite constant it's.
The prime generator is the prime generator, a completely different sequence.
This is going on forever. So we're looking at what the average tends to, uh,
to work out. The average,
you look at the proportion of these numbers
that are two. And so, and half of them are half of this.
Half of these numbers are two.
Then you would look at the proportion of these numbers that are three.
And if you look there, you can work out the proportion of threes.
You look at the proportions of fives and using those numbers,
you can add them up. You can find the average of the sequence.
Do you want to learn more about prime numbers and the visibility,
or how about any of these subjects? Look,
no matter what you're into brilliant is going to have the quizzes problems,
entire courses for you that are fun, interactive,
and lovingly designed to engage your brain, to make you smarter.
These aren't like homework or some kind of chore. They're fun.
They're stimulating. They're created by people who really know their stuff,
by the way, brilliant, loving the new design, such a great looking site,
go to brilliant.org/number file to see more and get
20% off a premium subscription that accesses everything on the side.
That's brilliant.org/number file signup for yourself.
Or maybe give brilliant as a gift.